معركه
224 يوما تنتهي بسقوط مدينه باخموت قائد
مجموعه فاجنر يعلن رافعا العالم الروسي
سيطره قواته الكامله على المدينه اعلان
سرعان ما كذبته
غير ان القياده الشرقيه في الجيش
الاوكراني قالت ان مغادرتها ستحدث عاجلا
ام اجلا
معركه با او كما اطلق عليها اسم ام
المعارك بدات في اكتوبر الماضي ودخلت
المدينه دائره صراع الروسي الاوكراني لكن
ماذا بعد
موسكو تامل ان تشكل المدينه منصه اطلاق
النحو المزيد من المكاسب الميدانيه
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه وفي قراءه سابقه
اشارت الى ان الاستيلاء على المدينه قد
يمكن روسيا من تهديد مناطق اكبر مثل
كروماتورسك وسلوفيانسك فيما يرى خبراء ان
التطور الاخير سيكشف منطقه دونيسك في
اقليم دومباس بالكامل امام المدفعيه
الروسيه الثقيله غير ان وزير الدفاع
الامريكي قلل في وقت سابق من اهميه سقوط
باخموت معتبرا ان ذلك لا يعني بالضروره
تغييرا في وجهه المعركه لكنها قد تحدث
ضررا معنويا على جبهات القتال وهو ما
تخشاه كييف
مشهد تمت من يرى فيه ان مجموعه فاجنر
ستذهب نحو اعاده هيكله صفوفها لتصبح منظمه
موازيه للجيش الروسي ذات عقيده راسخه
المدينه استعصت طيله تسعه اشهر فكشفت عن
خلافات عميقه بين موسكو وفاجنر وصلت حده
تلويح يفجين بريكوجين بانسحاب اعتبر
الكرملين تنفيذه خيانه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك
في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات